the cinema of the 70s really started in
1967 with the release of Bonnie and
Clyde we robbed banks one could argue
that we can separate Hollywood into two
eras the era before Bonnie and Clyde and
to be era after Bonnie and Clyde Bonnie
and Clyde is one of the most
revolutionary and groundbreaking movies
ever made it introduced film languished
never before seen in American cinema and
pushed the boundaries for what Hollywood
was capable of the film tells the story
of Bonnie and Clyde two outlaws robbing
banks during the Great Depression
through its daring style it's French
inspired script and its commentary on
both the past and the present Bonnie and
Clyde laid the groundwork for the future
and carved out a space in Hollywood for
the experimental and genre-bending films
of the 1970s so let's analyze the
opening scene to understand the film's
daring and innovative style the film
opens with an extreme closeup on a pair
of luscious lips already suggesting that
sexuality will play an important role in
the film throughout the scene the camera
tracks Bonnie closely it's a very
empathizing way to film the character
the cuts continue following her movement
but they skip over time in this frame
Bonnie just starts to stand up but in
the very next frame she's already
standing this happens throughout the
scene maintaining movement but skipping
over time
because movement is maintained the cuts
feel natural but the viewer still senses
the unease below the surface extreme
tracking close-ups combined with spatial
and temporal disruption convey the
tension felt within the character the
camera also reinforces this tension
visually by boxing the character into
frames within the frame in one shot
she's stuck inside the bed frame and
another inside the window frame in this
shot we get visual cues of her juvenile
state from the doll and trinkets in the
background and it's not a coincidence
that she's standing in front of a
birdcage all these choices seem pretty
bold but the editing is so seamless the
camerawork is so precise and the use of
space is so practical that the sequence
doesn't feel over-the-top or confusing
it perfectly conveys that Bonnie feels
trapped and uneasy with her life
the other thing choices in the opening
scene feel self-explanatory for a modern
viewer but this style of editing was
actually quite unusual for a Hollywood
film at that time so it's no surprise
that director Arthur Penn didn't get his
editing inspiration from America instead
he borrowed it from a group of
innovative filmmakers across the
Atlantic part of what makes Bonnie and
Clyde such a pivotal film was its
skillful repackaging of the innovations
of the French New Wave for an American
audience the New Wave was a film
movement all about breaking genre
conventions these films introduced
experimental techniques never used in
mainstream cinema such as discontinuous
editing and imaginative unusual
narratives journalist David Newman and
Robert Benton admired these filmmakers
and wanted to bring their innovations to
America so they wrote a screenplay that
took the iconic American gangster story
of Bonnie and Clyde and injected it with
the provocative style of the French New
Wave their initial script borrows
heavily from jean-luc Godard breathless
and Francois Truffaut's Jules and Jim
breathless is also about a couple on the
run and ends with a climactic shootout
it has the same editing techniques from
Bonnie and Clyde preserving movement but
distorting space and time Jules and Jim
had a similar influence on Bonnie and
Clyde the film centers on an
unconventional romance between two men
and a whimsical woman something in an
early draft of Bonnie and Clyde Neuman
and Benson also infused their script
with the relentless pace and dramatic
tonal shifts they admired in Jules and
Jim the initial script of Bonnie and
Clyde captured what made the wave so
exciting and remains in the final film
and Truffaut also influenced the film
directly Benson a Newman Center fo an
early draft at the screenplay and he
made many suggestions that made it into
the final film it must have been obvious
to Truffaut that the script had more
than enough French influence to become
an exciting and revolutionary gangster
film so he focused on making sure the
film would not be so unfamiliar to an
American audience that it wouldn't make
sense to them ironically his input
streamlines the scripts to fit Hollywood
norms and removed unnecessary scenes
that were meant to reflect the
meandering narratives of the French New
Wave as film critic Matthew Bernstein
puts it Truffaut focused not on opening
the film up to more playful disparate
elements but on unifying it to give it
greater aesthetic coherence the opening
scene is a perfect example of this idea
Truffaut added this opening scene
because the script originally opens with
Clyde following Bonnie on the street and
he felt that made their meeting too
abrupt Truffaut edition gives us a
stronger understanding of Bonnie's
personal conflict that drives the story
forward but at the same time Arthur Penn
shot and edited the opening scene still
using French techniques so we end up
with the best of both worlds a cohesive
story that also has the imaginative
French influence so by the time filming
started Pat had the difficult task of
shooting a French inspired script while
also making an American audience feel at
home
pan added familiar American imagery
through the film scenery like the FDR
posters and the okie truck of the family
who lost their house to the bank the
mother and child in this scene echo the
famous migrant mother photograph
Truffaut and Arthur Penn's contributions
made the film suitable for an American
audience while the French new-wave
influence gave it a brand-new style
the result is a groundbreaking film that
pushed stylistic and narrative
boundaries while still resonating with
an American audience
the film's compromise between French
influence and Americana resulted in a
film that went places no studio backed
film had ever gone in America the rest
of the opening scene shows just how far
this film went challenging Hollywood
norms of gender sex and violence when
Bonnie catches Clyde trying to steal her
mother's car she speaks the first line
in the movie the screenwriters picked
their words carefully throughout the
film and the opening scene is no
exception addressing him as boy implies
his youth and immaturity in a later
scene we find out he's impotent his
immaturity manifests itself sexually
right after he first fails to perform
she repeats her initial name Fran
boy she may label him as boyish but that
doesn't keep her from admiring his law
breaking a simple shot reverse shot
tells the whole story as the script puts
it before they speak they have become
co-conspirators Bonnie speaking to Clyde
from her window evokes the classic Romeo
and Juliet balcony scene but in this
version of the story she's completely
naked and he's about to steal her mom's
car they follow a similar star-crossed
lovers storyline as Romeo and Juliet but
they substitute innocent love for love
fueled by violence and criminality
throughout the film law breaking and
violent substitute for sex
Bonnie seductively strokes Clyde's gun
and after Clyde fails at having sex
again she cuddles with the gun Bonnie
and Clyde challenges conventional
American storytelling and in the same
way that the opening scene gives us a
new unusual twist to the classic Romeo
and Juliet young lovers the movie as a
whole introduced drastic tonal shifting
that was brand new for Hollywood the
film challenges expectations in a lot of
ways including its portrayal of the
Great Depression and its portrayal of
violence Bonnie and Clyde was one of the
first movies to portray the Great
Depression as kind of funny their
getaway chases seem ridiculous in their
tiny 1930s automobiles and they run into
humorous mishaps like not speaking loud
enough to get anyone's attention during
their robbery 1967 feels like the year
were just enough time passed after the
Great Depression to poke fun at it
thanks to Bonnie and Clyde filmmakers
continue to have fun with a simple
dim-witted Depression era South in
movies like oh brother where art thou
but the film doesn't stick to comedy it
creates a nervous imbalance between
slapstick humor and violent tragedy
during one robbery the gang can't find
their getaway car because their driver
parked and the mishap has played for
laughs but because of this mistake Clyde
has to kill somebody trying to stop them
the script describes the scene as funny
and horrible at the same time in Pauline
kales review of the film she notes that
Bonnie and Clyde was the first film to
artfully put the audience on the spot
for the first time we are the butt of
the joke we think we're clever for
getting the joke right until we catch
the first bullet right in the face to
make the juxtaposed
in between comedy and violence work the
film had to push the boundaries for both
not only was it the first movie to make
the Great Depression funny it was also
the first to make violence brutally
realistic it introduced the use of
squibs a small explosive device placed
on an actor that made it look like they
got hit by a bullet when characters get
shot in the film we feel the impact and
we see the injuries take a toll on them
this brand new realism enhanced the
comedy as much as it enhanced the
violence in one shootout the realistic
and brutal violence makes it gang
members frantic screaming that much more
hilarious the four Bonnie and Clyde
movies always told their story straight
dark comedies like dr. Strangelove had
been coming out for years before Bonnie
and Clyde but their satirical tone
remained consistent from beginning to
end
the juxtapositioning and Bonnie and
Clyde opened to the door for filmmakers
to play with audience expectations
towards tone and violence by 1969 we
were already seeing the effects the
extreme violence in the Wild Bunch and
the intense irony of Butch Cassidy and
the Sundance Kid Oh a lot - Bonnie and
Clyde and by the 70s it was in full
swing Francis Coppola himself copied the
brutal realism in Bonnie and Clyde for
The Godfather
by also using scripts and making the
violence feel raw and intense and any
modern movie that plays with emotional
expectations owes itself to the
revolutionary screenplay of Bonnie and
Clyde when Marvin gets shot in the face
and Pulp Fiction it feels just like the
banker getting shot in the face funny
and horrible at the same time and the
juxtaposition of Midwestern niceties and
gruesome murder in Fargo feels just like
a gang member flailing helplessly in the
middle of a shootout so what's a deal
now looks pretty bad so the next time
you watch a contemporary American film
with drastic shifts in tone bold editing
or audience challenging storylines don't
forget which couple started at all
thanks while Bonnie and Clyde did poke
fun at Depression era rural America it
also highlights the desperation people
felt over
time it's partially why bonnie is
willing to join father she has few other
economic prospects as a waitress and if
you want to learn more about this
tumultuous time in history
I'd recommend watching the two-part
documentary 1929
it's a riveting history of the stock
market crash and the Great Depression
and it's only available on curiosity
stream curiosity streams newly expanded
library has thousands of titles that
will send you down the rabbit hole on
topics like art science and history and
because they know that these are rapidly
changing times
curiosity stream is offering a 40
percent discount off annual plans right
now what better way to spend your
quarantine days than to expand your mind
and there's more to curiosity stream has
partnered with nebula the creator own
streaming service that I actually helped
build along with a bunch of other
creators you know and love there we're
posting all of our content ad-free as
well as creating nebula originals like
the ongoing series working titles it's a
series analyzing TV title sequences with
episodes by Patrick eet Willems just
right and yours truly and nebula
subscriptions are automatically included
with an annual subscription to curiosity
stream we hope this makes it easier to
hashtag stay at home so if you want to
try both curiosity stream and nebula
free for 30-days go to curiosity stream
comm slash now you see it and enter the
promo code now you see it when prompted
during the signup process
thanks to curiosity stream for
sponsoring and thanks to you our patrons
for your support if you want to support
our work directly join our patreon for
exclusive benefits thanks for watching